madame la Présidente
presque la séance est presque ouverte
je peux dire que le compte rendu
analytique de la prestance a été
distribuée vous demandez s'il y a des
observations
et que procès-verbal est donc adopté
sous les réserves d'usage
bien l'ordre du jour appelle le débat
sur le thème Comment rendre possible le
retour en Ukraine des enfants déportés
en Fédération de Russie à la demande du
groupe des rassemblements des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants je vous
rappelle que dans ce départ le
gouvernement à la Faculté si le juge
nécessaire de prendre la parole
immédiatement après chaque correcteur
pour une durée de 2 minutes
l'orateur disposerait alors à son tour
du droit de répartie pour une minute
madame la ministre vous pourrez donc si
vous le souhaitez répondre après chaque
orateur une fois que celui-ci a retrouvé
une place dans l'hémicycle ou répondre à
la fin du débat de manière globale c'est
vous faites comme vous le souhaitez la
parole est tout d'abord alors attend du
groupe qui a demandé ce débat c'est à
dire Monsieur André gatelin pour le
groupe du RDPI
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues depuis la
nuit des temps les atrocités qui
entourent chaque conflit chaque guerre
sont légion et témoignent
malheureusement de la face obscure est
terrible de ce que nous osons encore
appelé l'humanité la première moitié du
XXe siècle a traversé deux conflits
mondiaux mais aussi les nombreux
génétiques perpétrés tant à l'encontre
des Arméniens des populations juives ou
des paysans ukrainiens ont illustré ce
que d'aucun appelle la guerre totale
c'est-à-dire non plus une guerre dans
les implications et les conséquences se
limiteraient aux seuls champs de
bataille et à l'affrontement entre les
forces armées rivales mais une guerre
qui implique l'ensemble des populations
y compris celle civile les plus
vulnérables et les plus innocentes qui
soient nous avons ainsi découvert que
les enfants n'étaient plus seulement des
victimes à directe des conflits mais
qu'elles en étaient de plus en souvent
des cibles et des otages délibérés
depuis un siècle déporté assimilé de
force jusqu'à tuer délibérément l'enfant
de l'ennemi est devenu une des méthodes
caractéristiques des régimes
totalitaires en guerre contre leur
voisins ou contre une partie même de
leur population la Quatrième Convention
de Genève de 1949 relative à la
protection des personnes civiles en
temps de guerre a précisément été édicté
avec l'objectif de mettre fin à ses
pratiques inadmissibles ces exactions
qui sont des crimes contre l'humanité et
parfois même des crimes de génocide
n'ont pas pour autant cesser elles ont
continué d'être à l'oeuvre ces dernières
années en Asie en Afrique ou encore en
Amérique latine même en Europe on a vu
cette guerre de terreur mise en pratique
en ex Yougoslavie au début des années
mais ce qui se passe depuis le début de
la guerre d'invasion lancée par la
fédération bruciale en compte de
l'Ukraine n'a pas en termes d'atrocité
de précédents en Europe depuis 1945 et
parmi ces atrocités sans limites et
sciemment orchestrées par tout un régime
le sort qui est réservé aux enfants
Ukrainiens arrachés à leur famille et à
leur pays et sans doute le plus ignoble
et le plus révoltant qui soit dans le
mépris total du droit international la
Russie procède depuis plus d'un an un
transfert forcé et massif d'enfants
Ukrainiens vers son territoire
officiellement afin de les préserver des
horreurs d'un conflit que le Kremlin a
lui-même déclenché car c'est là une
autre caractéristique des régimes
totalitaires que de mettre la jeunesse
et des enfants au cœur de leur
rhétorique propagandiste et de leur
mécanique systématique de désinformation
enlever et déporté devient accueillir et
protéger éradiquer la culture
ukrainienne et russifiée devient éduquée
et intégré
les premiers transferts forcés de civils
et particulièrement ceux d'enfants ont
débuté dès les premières semaines de
l'agression russe ils se sont amplifiés
au fur et à mesure des conquêtes
territoriales de l'armée russe
l'ouverture de couloirs
presque tous orientés vers le territoire
russe et ont fortement contribué dans
les zones de combat qui touchent souvent
à distance
civiles et les forces militaires des
millions d'habitants de l'est et du sud
de l'Ukraine dont plus de 700 000
enfants au dire des autorités russes ce
serait ou aurait été déplacé pas
toujours volontairement loin sans faut
vers le territoire de la Russie tout
cela s'est fait sous le contrôle
exclusif des autorités du Kremlin sans
la présence naturellement sur le terrain
des organisations internationales et
encore moins des autorités ukrainiennes
c'est la raison principale qui explique
que ce phénomène de déportation forcée
était durant les premiers mois et de
mort encore aujourd'hui aussi mal
documenté et quantifier il est difficile
encore aujourd'hui de connaître
objectivement la population
ukrainienne qui a été déplacée vers la
Russie et parmi celles-ci la part de
population qui a véritablement été
déporté de force le sort des enfants est
encore plus délicat et évalué ce n'est
que depuis début février dernier que
grâce au travail d'enquête méticuleux
mais malheureusement encore trop partiel
conduit par l'Université de Yale que
nous avons un peu plus sur l'horrible
mécanique des déportations systémiques
qui ont été mises en oeuvre par les
autorités russes c'est ainsi que nous
avons appris l'existence d'une
quarantaine au moins de camps de
déportation sur le territoire de la
fédération l'existence aussi de
véritables centres de tri nombre
d'enfants à peine arrivé en Russie ont
été séparés de leur famille et de leurs
parents pourraient ensuite envoyer vers
des camps de rééducation ou êtes-vous et
au placement de force dans des familles
russes après changement de leur nom et
de l'orétat civil nous savons désormais
sans cependant pouvoir documenter
précisément chaque cas que des milliers
d'enfants parfois âgés de quelques mots
seulement on fait l'objet de véritables
rafle au sein d'orphelinat d'école ou de
maternité dans les régions occupées à
cette horreur s'ajoute aussi un drame
dans le drame celui qui fait mini des
familles qui dans les zones d'intenses
combat ont été sollicités enfin afin
d'envoyer leurs enfants pour quelques
semaines dans de prétendues colonies de
vacances hors des zones de combat et
pour les protéger de la guerre des
enfants qui de nombreux mois après ne
sont toujours pas revenus mes chers
collègues je vous demande un instant
d'imaginer le terrible sentiment de
culpabilité qui pèse aujourd'hui sur ses
parents qui de bonne foi ont donné leur
assentiment pour l'envoi de leurs
enfants dans ses colonies sans retour
tous ces éléments ajoutés au fait qu'il
est impossible aujourd'hui d'investiguer
sur les territoires Ukrainiens toujours
sur le contrôle des forces et que le
travail d'enquête ne sera guère facilité
même lorsque c'est territoire seront
reconquis tant les autorités russes
s'acharnent à détruire de manière
systématique toutes les preuves qui
pourraient conduire à l'air
incrimination tous ces éléments disaient
donc justifie que ces crimes
véritablement constitutifs d'un crime
d'un acte de génocide soit instamment
dénoncé et que les États et les
institutions internationales en
application précisément du Droit
International s'engage forcément à
mettre s'engage formellement pardon à
mettre en oeuvre tous les moyens humains
scientifiques et technologiques dont ils
disposent pour documenter précisément
cette insupportable exaction et exercer
toutes les pressions possibles pour
permettre dans les médias délais le
retour des enfants du krainien déport il
y a là une urgence vitale pour des
centaines de milliers d'enfants et leurs
familles il y a urgence aussi à tenter
de documenter au plus près et au plus
vite c'est terrible exactions car rien
ne se respire que les responsables de
ces que de ses déportations massives et
sciemment organisées jouissent demain
d'une impunité juridique par manque de
preuve il n'y a pas de paix possible
sans justice il n'y a pas de
possibilités pour ces enfants de se
reconstruire un jour sans connu soyons
en mesure de leur garantir la justice
rien que la justice met toute la justice
c'est le sens de la proposition de
résolution que j'avais déposée le 10
février dernier au Sénat une résolution
qui a été largement réactualisée et
enrichie grâce aux apports de nos
collègues notamment notre collègue Nadia
ce logo président du groupe d'amitié
France-Ukraine et bien sûr l'apport de
Claude Kern et de Joël garioménam qui
ont été rapporteurs respectivement de ce
texte devant la commission des affaires
européennes et devant la commission des
affaires étrangères de notre haute
assemblée c'est grâce à eux et à vous
tous que dans un élan véritablement
transpartisan notre résolution a été
adoptée à l'unanimité dans nos deux
commissions et qu'elle est formellement
devenue résolution du Sénat le 17 avril
dernier je vous en remercie je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
avant de donner la parole à l'orateur
suivant je voudrais mes chers collègues
vous informer de la présence dans les
tribunes de Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
d'Ukraine et le remercier d'assister à
nos débats la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur Jacques le nez pour
vous
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues la guerre en Ukraine
pousse une génération d'enfants au bord
du précipice qui traîne UNICEF dans un
article de février 2023 depuis plus d'un
an les civils ukrainiens et plus
particulièrement les 8 millions
d'enfants du pays
subissent les horreurs de la guerre
crise économique confrontation à la
violence c'est à la mort privation de
l'accès aux services de base sont
malheureusement les conséquences
habituelles de tout conflit armé mais il
semble que cela ne suffisent pas à la
Fédération de Russie
non le doublement du pourcentage
d'enfants vivants dans la pauvreté en
Ukraine depuis le début du conflit ne
suffit pas non l'exposition de près de 1
million 500 000 enfants à un problème de
santé mentale directement lié au conflit
ne suffit pas non l'interruption de
l'éducation de plus de 5 millions
d'enfants et la restriction de l'accès
aux soins de milliers d'entre eux ne
suffisent pas chers collègues il a fallu
que la Fédération de Russie y rajoute
l'enfer de la déportation à ce jour et
selon les autorités ukrainiennes plus de
19 000 enfants Ukrainiens demeurent en
Russie après y avoir été transféré de
force et cette estimation ne tient même
pas compte des enfants vivants dans les
territoires occupés
ces transfert forcés n'ont rien d'une
colonie de vacances comme aimerait nous
le faire croire les autorités russes ils
ont commencé avant même le début du
conflit lorsque les pensionnaires des
orphelinats et les enfants handicapés
des territoires du donuts et de l'ougans
est à déplacer en Fédération de Russie
ou en Biélorussie
depuis février 2022 cependant le
mouvement s'est accéléré et amplifié
d'abord en s'attaquant brutalement aux
infrastructures civiles et aux espaces
résidentiels Ukrainiens les forces
russes contraignent de nombreuses
familles des régions frontalières à
s'exiler vers la Russie là un filtrage
est mené pour séparer les enfants de
leurs parents dans les zones de combat
se filtrage se résume parfois au meurtre
des parents et à l'enlèvement des
orphelins comme le précise la résolution
adoptée par l'Assemblée parlementaire du
Conseil de l'Europe le 27 avril dernier
une fois transféré les enfants sont
placés en foyer ou en famille d'accueil
et leur procédure d'adoption est
facilité afin d'accélérer la
russification
car c'est bien de cela dont il s'agit la
rééducation des enfants l'effacement de
leur identité ukrainienne et leur
endoctrinement sont les lignes de la
politique russe très concrètement cela
se traduit par l'attribution forcée de
la citoyenneté russe l'interdiction de
parler ukrainien ou de manifester un
quelconque signe d'appartenance à la
culture ukrainienne et l'exposition
obligatoire à la langue à la culture et
à la propagande russe ses faits sont
évidemment contraires au droit
international humanitaires et
constitutive de crimes de guerre et de
crimes contre l'humanité j'ajoute qu'il
réponde à la définition du crime de
génocide tel qui établit par la
convention de 1948
qui décrit ce dernier comme un acte
commis dans l'intention de détruire en
tout ou partie un groupe national ennemi
racial ou religieux et notamment le
transfert forcer d'enfants du groupe un
autre groupe chers collègues vous aurez
peut-être du mal à croire mais la Russie
a signé ratifié cette convention c'est
pourquoi au nom du groupe de l'Union
centriste je salue l'initiative de notre
collègue André Cathelin
ayant permis au Sénat par une résolution
adoptée le 17 avril dernier de condamner
fermement les déportations d'enfants
Ukrainiens par la Fédération de Russie
notre assemblée joint ainsi savoir à
celle de l'Organisation des Nations
Unies du Parlement européen et de
l'Organisation pour la sécurité la
coopération en Europe
toutes ont exprimé leur indignation
vis-à-vis des transferts forcés
d'enfants et d'autres civils Ukrainiens
vers la Russie et exiger la condamnation
ferme des responsables de cette
politique d'État
par une résolution votée le 27 avril
dernier l'Assemblée parlementaire du
Conseil de l'Europe où j'ai l'honneur de
siéger n'ont pas non plus hésité à
qualifier les enlèvements d'enfants
Ukrainiens d'actes génocidaire si
l'ensemble de la communauté
internationale s'insurge c'est parce que
cet enjeu dépasse le seul cadre du
conflit entre l'Ukraine et la Russie
pour reprendre les mots de Madame Olena
zelenska à la première dame d'Ukraine
s'exprimant au Conseil de la semaine
dernière quand les droits de l'enfant
sont menacés dans un pays du monde les
droits de l'enfant sont menacés par tout
dans ce contexte chers collègues il nous
faut d'abord traiter l'urgence notre
priorité doit être d'organiser le retour
des enfants Ukrainiens déportés avant
que le lavage de cerveau auquel ils sont
soumis les phases définitivement leur
identité avec mes collègues de l'Union
centriste je répète l'invitation faite
au gouvernement français et à l'Union
européenne de faire pression sur les
autorités russes pour que les
organisations humanitaires
internationales nationale puisse avoir
accès aux enfants déportés
déterminent leur nombre réel et leur
identité puis organise leur rapatriement
ensuite viendra le temps de la justice
je salue la décision d'un cours pénale
internationale du 17 mars 2023 des
maîtres des mandats d'arrêt contre
Vladimir Poutine et contre la
commissaire russe au droit des enfants
Maria volva Belova il serait toutefois
souhaitable que ces mandats d'Arès
soient élargis à l'ensemble de la chaîne
des responsables de la mise en œuvre des
transferts forcés et sa compagne d'un
nouveau train de sanction européenne
visant les revenus et le patrimoine de
ses responsables pour que justice soit
faite il importe dès à présent de bien
documenter et de recenser tous les cas
de transfert forcés par la création d'un
registre international des dommages les
faits sont têtus il a Fédération de
Russie ne pourra pas fuir ses
responsabilités indéfiniment mes chers
collègues je souhaite que le débat qui
se tient aujourd'hui au Sénat envoie un
signal fort au gouvernement français à
l'Union européenne et aux institutions
internationales que la Fédération de
Russie soit prise due nous ne fermerons
pas les yeux nous ne Terrons pas et nous
n'oublierons pas les enfants Ukrainiens
sont nos enfants et nos enfants sont
notre avenir préparons l'avenir je vous
remercie de votre attention
la parole est maintenant madame
estamenda
le 11 mars 2023 le bureau du procureur
général du crâne annoncé qu'au moins 464
enfants
ukrainiennes sont morts depuis le début
du conflit et plus de 16000 enfants sont
déportés en Russie je ne pensais pas de
voir l'employé le terme de déportés que
je mets en guillemets ça a commencé déjà
en 1453 avec la prise de Constantinople
par mes mètres de qui a déporté des
populations pour remplacer les Byzantins
et je ne vais pas faire la série de ce
déportations qui ont quand même horrifié
l'Europe
après les événements et
qu'aujourd'hui cette déportation
rappelle quand même
les heures les plus sombres de notre
histoire
rien ne semble freiner Vladimir Poutine
à l'encontre duquel un mandra un mandat
d'arrêt pour déportation illégale
d'enfants était mis par la CPI dans une
résolution votée le 27 avril dernier le
Conseil de l'Europe qualifie les
enlèvements d'enfants ukrainienne vers
la Russie de crime de génocide exigent
leur rapatriement par ailleurs l'ONG
Save Ukraine a réussi à organiser le
rapatrième le rapatriement de 17 enfants
ukrainienne faute d'accord diplomatique
entre Kiev et Moscou l'association save
Ukraine doit se plier aux règles
strictes de l'administration russe son
action demeure alors très limité
quels moyens humains et financier
pouvons-nous apporter à cette ONG quelle
action diplomatique est-il possible
d'engager auprès des autorités russes
nous ne devons pas nous habituer à ces
images insoutenables à ces déportations
à ces actions notre devoir de mémoire
nous oblige à ne surtout pas abandonner
ces enfants
ukrainiennes qui auraient pu être les
nôtres merci
bien la parole et maintenant monsieur
André guillaule pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues nous remercions le
groupe RDPI à l'initiative de ce débat
et André cadolin pour son efficace sur
le sujet
comme si la guerre ne se portait pas un
aile suffisamment d'atrocité
l'imagination du pouvoir russe en la
matière et sans limite après l'invasion
de l'Ukraine le 24 février 2022 précédé
de l'annexion de la Crimée en 2014
ponctuée de bombardements de ville
d'hôpitaux d'école nous découvrons la
déportation de milliers d'enfants
Ukrainiens vers la Fédération de Russie
des centaines de femmes de la région de
Carson soustrait à leurs parents
prétextant de jolies colonies de
vacances ou encore enlevés après
l'assassinat ou l'arrestation d'un
parent ou tout autre insupportable
superfuge pour ses enlèvements générants
désarroi et malheurs des familles
ukrainiennes
ce sont des milliers d'enfants ainsi
déportés mais comment connaître le
chiffre exact près de 20 000 clairement
identifiés ou 10 fois plus selon les
autorités ukrainiennes comment rendre
possible le retour en Ukraine de tous
ces enfants déportés c'est une difficile
question qui nous préoccupe aujourd'hui
dans le contexte d'une guerre durable
il est bien évident qu'il faut tout
d'abord soutenir financièrement toutes
les organisations humanitaires
impliquées dans la recherche et le
rapatriement des jeunes victimes ainsi
que les autorités ukrainiennes déjà très
investies pour comptabiliser les
familles concernées et recenser toutes
les formes dans l'élèvement utilisées
l'association seuiles connaît bien le
processus post enlèvement ce qui devrait
permettre au gouvernement ukrainien et
la communauté internationale
l'identification et la localisation des
enfants déportés il faut absolument
mobiliser les moyens humains et
matériels en faveur de la poursuite de
ce travail d'inventaire et d'affinage
des données sur ces enfants qui soient
dans des familles d'accueil ou dans des
camps
la pression diplomatique est également
nécessaire mais sous un angle très
spécifique puisque la nature de ce
problème n'entre pas dans le processus
connu les échanges de prisonniers de
guerre et la Russie ne peut pas
reconnaître la bassesse de ces
agissements de déportation d'enfants
illégales qui n'ont pas conséquent pas
d'existence officielle il appartient à
la Croix Rouge et à l'ONU dans la Russie
rappelons-le vient de prendre la
présidence du Conseil de sécurité de
mettre en place un dispositif de
règlement pour le cas où il adviendrait
faut-il rappeler que la Russie a ratifié
la Convention sur les droits de l'enfant
et la partie aussi à la France de faire
porter à l'Aude du jour du Conseil de
sécurité la question des droits des
enfants sur la base de la résolution
2427 adoptés en 2018 et d'inviter la
Russie à contribuer à résoudre ce type
de situation
et mettre ainsi la Russie et Vladimir
Poutine devant leur contradiction
aujourd'hui chaque récupération
d'enfants est une opération unique et
repose sur des contacts informels et
dangereux
le temps joue contre les enfants qui
sont russifiés endocrinées une approche
globale s'impose donc une doctrine de
prévention doit être mise à travers deux
axes le premier reviendrait bien entendu
aux autorités ukrainiennes autant que
faire ce peu d'éloigner du théâtre de
guerre le maximum d'enfants mineurs en
second lieu nous devons mener une guerre
informationnelle positive si j'ose dire
en utilisant les réseaux sociaux qui
pour le coup porteraient enfin bien leur
nom il s'agirait là de mettre des
familles d'accueils russes devant le
responsabilité alors qu'elle ne pense
remplir une action d'évaluation
d'évacuation humanitaire en plaçant ses
enfants en dehors des zones de combat
ces familles servent-elles qu'elles sont
en réalité complices de crimes de guerre
une qualification déjà retenue par une
commission d'enquête de l'ONU il faut
pouvoir le leur dire
j'en viens ainsi un autre volet celui de
la réponse judiciaire la Cour pénale
internationale a été saisie c'est une
bonne chose on peut en effet se réjouir
des deux mandats d'arrêt émis par le en
mars dernier par le CPI pour crime de
guerre de déportation illégale d'enfants
Ukrainiens un contre le président russe
et l'autre contre Maria lova Belova sa
commissaire ou droit de l'enfant bien
entendu Vladimir Poutine conteste
légitimité de ses procédures il
n'empêche le dirigeant est encore
davantage au banc de la communauté
internationale rappelons russe au
rappelons aux Russes le vieillardage
bien mal acquis ne profite jamais et
leur dire que ses enfants dont le
pouvoir russe souhaitent les dresser
contre l'Ukraine et contre l'Occident
sont de véritables bombes à retardements
pour leur identité russe pour un peuple
qui mérite bien mieux que cela au regard
de son histoire je vous remercie
la parole est maintenant madame Pascal à
la présidente Pascal grunis pour 10
minutes pour le groupe les républicains
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues nous allons beaucoup
nous répéter ce matin mais je crois que
nous répéterons encore il faudra encore
se répéter et Madame la Ministre à vous
de fédérer toute la communauté
internationale en compte sur vous depuis
maintenant plus d'un an l'invasion russe
de l'Ukraine se poursuit et avec elle
son cortège de mort de souffrance et de
destruction les dizaines de milliers de
vie qu'elle a enlevé les millions de
destins qu'elle a brisé nous heurtent au
plus profond ils sont pour reprendre les
mots d'Antonio Guterres un affront à
notre conscience collective
naturellement chacune des victimes de
cette absurde agression éveillons-nous
un sentiment de compassion d'indignation
et parfois de légitime colère mais
certaines instinctivement nous révoltent
les enfants symboles du martyr de
l'innocence aux mains de la barbarie
sont les victimes que nous voudrions ne
jamais avoir à déplorer
et pourtant moins 500 d'entre ont déjà
été tués depuis le début des hostilités
plus d'un millier ont été blessés et un
nombre incalculable subi d'une manière
ou d'une autre le chaos engendré par la
guerre ils sont orphelins séparés de
leur famille déplacées en Ukraine ou
exilé en Europe ils vivent dans des
conditions dangereuses et précaires où
sont exposés au risque d'abus et
d'exploitation en tout genre ils sont
aussi déportés en Russie oui déportés ce
mot que l'on croyait banni à jamais du
vocabulaire européen et pourtant celui
qui s'impose pour nommer la réalité
vécue par tant d'enfants Ukrainiens
entre les 20000 qui ont été
officiellement identifiés par le
gouvernement ukrainien et les 700 000
évoqués par plusieurs sources y compris
russes il reste extrêmement difficile de
savoir combien d'entre eux sont touchés
par ce rap de masse
mais si l'ampleur du phénomène reste à
déterminer avec précision son existence
elle ne souffre d'aucune contestation
d'autant que comble du cynisme elle est
revendiquée par les autorités russes
elles-mêmes qui prétendent sauver ses
enfants en les mettant à l'abri des
combats certes la rhétorique du Kremlin
nous avait habitué de longue date à ces
accommodements avec la vérité mais
depuis le début de l'opération militaire
spéciale en Ukraine la propagande russe
se mit en caricature du 1984 d'Orwell
jour après jour elle donne raison à ce
génitine pour qui tout homme qui choisit
la violence comme moyen doit
inexorablement choisir le mensonge comme
règle ces mensonges auxquelles personne
ne peut décemment croire son proféré
pour étayer tant bien que mal un récit
bancal que Moscou sèchine a construire
pour justifier sa guerre
dans cette réalité alternative les
dirigeants Ukrainiens sont ravalés au
rang de néo-nazie contrôlant le poste
avancé d'un Occident belliqueux et
menaçant la Russie quant à l'Ukraine
elle n'est qu'une province injustement
arrachée à la mère patrie et la nation
ukrainienne depuis toujours qu'on
substantielle à la nation russe n'existe
tout simplement pas chacun peut s'en
rendre compte en contemplant le courage
et la détermination avec lesquels les
Ukrainiens défendent leur pays la fable
russe est une incroyable inconsistance
alors pour que la réalité rejoigne un
temps soit peu la fiction Moscou cherche
par tous les moyens à russifier les
territoires soumis dans cette mécanique
l'enlèvement d'enfants à grande échelle
occupe occupe une place tout à fait
centrale car déporter les enfants c'est
avant tout chercher à priver l'Ukraine
de son identité et surtout de son avenir
et pour servir cette emprise les Russes
et leurs affidés ont mis en place un
véritable système aussi complexe
qu'instidieux celui-ci débute avec le
ciblage des enfants qui doivent être
isolés de leur famille ce qui se trouve
déjà placé en institution ou en
orphelinat ceux qui sont hospitalisés ou
ceux qui sont séparés de leurs parents
dans les sinistres camps de filtration
sont les plus touchés mais les autorités
russes poussent la perfidie jusqu'à
inciter les familles ukrainiennes à
envoyer leurs enfants dans ce qui est
présenté comme des colonies de vacances
loin des zones à risque pour certains le
parcours se poursuit avec leur transfert
dans les camps de rééducation
disséminés sur tout le territoire russe
jusqu'en Sibérie l'objectif de cette
troublante évocation du Goulag est à la
fois simple et terrible
ex-cirper leur identité ukrainienne et
les conditionner à devenir
d'authentiques citoyens russes
pour d'autres il se termine avec leur
adoption par des familles russes
présentées comme un acte de pure
bienveillance plusieurs décrets ont
d'ailleurs été pris pour encourager les
processus d'adoption mais aussi pour
simplifier les procédures de changement
d'identité de nationalité et de
filiation de ses enfants en droit
international ces actes s'apparentent
largement aux crimes de génocide seule
l'intention finale bien qu'elle
apparaisse assez évidente reste
semble-t-il à caractériser sans
équivoque il relève en revanche sans
ambiguïté de la catégorie des crimes de
guerre c'est d'ailleurs cette
qualification qui a été retenue par la
Cour pénale internationale pour lancer
le 17 mars un mandat d'arrêt
international à l'encontre de la
commissaire russe au droit de l'enfant
mais aussi surtout à l'encontre de
Vladimir Poutine
c'est poursuites internationales qui
visent le chef d'un État membre
permanent du Conseil de sécurité des
Nations unies sont un véritable coup de
tonnerre diplomatique qui témoignent de
l'extrême gravité des faits et à défaut
de pouvoir être immédiatement condamné
au plan judiciaire puisque la Russie
n'est pas partie au Statut de Rome ils
doivent l'être en plan politique avec la
dernière fermeté
l'intitulé du débat de ce jour nous
invite toutefois à aller au-delà de la
nécessaire condamnation de ses crimes et
à nous interroger sur la manière de
rendre possible le retour des enfants
déportés en Russie jusqu'à présent rien
ni les revers militaires ni la
contestation intérieure ni les sanctions
n'ont permis de faire reculer Vladimir
Poutine nos moyens d'action peuvent donc
sembler relativement limitées et
toutefois indispensables pour tenter de
les prévenir autant que possible de
faire connaître les méfaits des
autorités russes vis-à-vis de ses
enfants
notre débat modestement il contribue
comme y contribue la résolution
européenne récemment adoptée sur
l'initiative de notre collègue André
gatolin et sur le rapport de notre autre
collègue Joël gariaume merci André il
s'agit d'un préalable indispensable au
maintien voire à l'accentuation de la
pression internationale sur ce sujet et
comme le sujet le suggère la résolution
européenne du Sénat le gouvernement
pourrait dans ce contexte impulser une
initiative diplomatique multilatérale
son objectif devrait être double d'une
part permettre l'accès des organisations
humanitaires à ses enfants et d'autre
part ouvrir des canaux de communication
et surtout des routes de retour il est
surtout fondamental qu'à travers cette
initiative les familles ukrainiennes
sachent qu'elles ne sont pas seules et
que nous nous tenons à leur côté
certaines d'entre elles se sont lancées
avec un courage confondant dans des
périples vertigineux pour retrouver la
trace de leurs enfants franchissant
parfois plusieurs frontières pour
contourner les lignes de front et
parcourant des milliers de kilomètres y
compris en territoire russe des
institutions et ONG ukrainiennes
accompagnent ce combat et accomplissent
une tâche colossale de recensement
d'identification et de localisation des
enfants sans leur travail qui se
conjugue aux enquêtes menées par
certaines instances internationales le
rapatriement des enfants Ukrainiens
resteraient sans doute un vœu pieux
grâce à elle un peu plus de 300 enfants
aujourd'hui à ce jour ont pu retrouver
leur pays voir leur famille cela montre
que malgré le danger malgré l'immensité
des difficultés leur retour est possible
fournir à ces structures tout le soutien
possible qu'il soit humain technique
matériel ou financier voilà une autre
piste d'action mise en avant par la
résolution et à laquelle je ne peux
évidemment que souscrire madame la
ministre l'Ukraine a besoin de notre
aide pour se faire cesser l'invasion
continuons demain comme nous l'avons
fait hier et comme nous le faisons
aujourd'hui à la lui apporter sans
réserve mais ses enfants ses familles
ont aussi besoin de notre aide alors
soyons au rendez-vous de la dignité la
plus élémentaire de l'avenir aussi pour
que cette génération d'enfants
traumatisée à vie par la guerre ne
devienne pas en plus une génération
volée et je me permets de vous rappeler
un de mes souvenirs de philo
où j'avais eu à répondre à cette phrase
l'accuma peut-il être inhumain je crois
que nous avons notre réponse ici
aujourd'hui merci
merci
la parole est maintenant madame Colette
mélo pour le groupe Les Indépendants
Poutine tente de faire disparaître
l'Ukraine il a affirmé qu'elle n'était
ni un pays ni un état
le dictateur russe a d'abord grignoté le
territoire ukrainien la Crimée le
dombases ayant avant de tenter une
invasion totale
cette initiative est pour l'heure un
échec sanglant l'offensive s'enlise mais
elle continue elle a fait périr des
milliers de personnes et un a déplacé
des millions malgré l'aide
internationale le sort de l'Ukraine
demeure encore incertain dans sa guerre
d'agression qui dure depuis plus d'un an
maintenant Poutine vise délibérément les
populations civiles il a concentré ses
tirs sur des installations énergétiques
civiles avant l'hiver les quartiers
d'habitation et même les maternités on
ne compte plus les exactions commises
par les criminels de la Wagner ou les
cadirovites les atrocités de bout de
chat illustrent la haine nourri par le
Kremlin contre le peuple ukrainien
le rapport des Nations Unies publiait le
15 mars dernier souligne l'ampleur des
exécutions sommaires la cruauté des
actes de torture et des violences
sexuelles commises par les troupes
russes contre la population civile
ukrainienne malgré la tragédie grâce au
courage ukrainien et au soutien
international l'Ukraine résiste à
l'envahisseur si Poutine a pour
l'instant échoué à prendre le contrôle
du pays il poursuit néanmoins son
travail d'effacement en niant la culture
ukrainienne en refusant à la nation
ukrainienne le droit de disposer
d'elle-même en lui refusant un avenir
dans ce contexte plus de 16 000 enfants
Ukrainiens auraient été transférés de
force des territoires occupés vers les
terres russes les enfants de l'Ukraine
sont son avenir et la Russie de Poutine
cherche à s'en emparer
des camps et autres lieux aménagés
auraient été installés sur le territoire
russe certains en Sibérie les enfants de
tout âge ils seraient rééduqués pour
devenir prorus les déportations de
jeunes Ukrainiens sont également devenus
le maillon stratégique d'un système
d'adoption misère en place par l'État et
géré par la commissaire au droit de
l'enfant en Russie depuis 2021 alors que
l'adoption d'enfants étrangers sans le
consentement du pays d'origine est
interdite en Russie
ces transferts forcés d'enfants et leur
soi-disant rééducation
constitue une atteinte non seulement aux
familles concernées mais à la nation
ukrainienne tout entière ces actes sont
constitutifs du crime de génocide il
vise à effacer dans l'esprit de ces
jeunes Ukrainiens l'idée même de leur
patrie nous ne pouvons pas l'accepter à
travers l'adoption de la région de la
résolution européenne portée par notre
collègue André gatolin que je salue le
Sénat a eu l'occasion d'affirmer son
opposition à ces transferts contraires
au droit international aujourd'hui
encore nous voulons dire à quel point
nous donnons l'agression de Poutine et à
quel point nous condamnons les actes
commis contre la population
ukrainienne il faut aussi trouver le
moyen de remédier à cette situation
c'est tout l'objet du débat qui nous
occupe
comme les auteurs de la résolution
européenne l'ont indiqué il est
essentiel de faire toute la lumière sur
ces événements il faut pour cela mener
des investigations poussées sur ces
transferts
identifier les filières existantes
permettra de connaître le mode
opératoire et les personnes concourantes
à ces transferts ces individus sont
complices d'un crime contre l'humanité
et doivent être traités comme tel
justice doit être rendue ces
investigations doivent à outre permettre
de retrouver les traces d'enfants déjà
transférés il est indispensable que ces
milliers d'enfants soient rendus à leur
famille et retrouvent leur patrie au
plus tôt nous avons dit que les
transferts forcés d'enfants sont
constitutifs d'un crime contre
l'humanité tous les acteurs de la
communauté internationale qui le peuvent
contribuer à faire cesser ses crimes
tant les États et les institutions
internationales que les ONG la guerre
des par Poutine pèsera durablement sur
les relations internationales et la
sécurité de notre continent avant le
début de ce conflit la France a œuvré
pour la paix elle est aujourd'hui à
engager aux côtés de la résistance
ukrainienne en plus en plus de fournir à
Kiev les moyens de résister nous devons
faire notre possible pour faire cesser
les crimes de Poutine nous l'avons fait
à envoyer des équipes sur les sites de
massacres contre boucha pour élucider
les crimes passées nous devons à présent
faire tout notre possible pour préserver
l'avenir de l'Ukraine en commençant par
celui de ses enfants c'est absolument
essentiel
merci la parole est maintenant à
Guillaume Gontard président du groupe
écologie solidarité territoire
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur l'Ambassadeur
je souhaiterais d'abord remercier notre
collègue André gatolin pour cette
initiative et ce débat sur le retour en
Ukraine des enfants déportés en
Fédération de Russie ce débat fait suite
au vote d'une résolution transpartisane
17 avril dernier et il était
particulièrement important indispensable
que notre assemblée se joigne à
l'indignation de la communauté
internationale c'est une question de
justice de respect du droit
international depuis plus d'un an le
dictateur russe dans une guerre
ignoble utilise les moyens les plus
abjects
les civils les enfants les femmes en
sont les premières victimes
crimes de guerre viol comme arme de
guerre enlèvement d'enfants rien
n'arrête Vladimir Poutine c'est une
stratégie militaire visant à
déshumaniser les victimes et à
terroriser les populations
l'armée russe ne recule devant aucune
barbarie pour tenter de saper le moral
du peuple ukrainien depuis le début de
l'invasion de l'Ukraine par la Russie
les autorités ukrainiennes estiment que
plus de 16000 enfants ont été enlevés
par les autorités russes les enlevant
les enfants enlevés pardon sont emmenés
dans des camps de rééducation qui vise à
les endocriner et les rendre prurus dans
certains cas un entraînement militaire
est également au programme leurs
conditions de vie dans ces camps sont
épouvantables vêtements sales insultes
manque de soin les témoignages des
enfants revenus de ces camps sont
difficiles à entendre l'objectif de
Poutine est de faire adopter ses enfants
par des familles russes c'est pour
poursuivre cet objectif qu'il a assoupli
la loi russe sur l'adoption et la
naturalisation des enfants Ukrainiens
selon l'ONG man Wright watch en décembre
dernier 400 enfants Ukrainiens avaient
déjà été adoptés par des familles russes
menaces d'utiliser l'arme nucléaire
bombardement de civils torture emploi de
mercenaires attaquent des établissements
médicaux et depuis quelques mois
enlèvement d'enfants Ukrainiens la
Russie la Russie ne recule devant aucune
exaction pour conduire sa guerre
d'agression
ces agissements sont inacceptables et
doivent cesser comme l'a dit le
procureur de la Cour pénale
internationale les enfants ne peuvent
pas être traités comme un butin de
guerre
malgré la qualification de ces
agissements comme crime de guerre par
l'ONU et les missions d'un mandat
d'arrêt de la Cour pénale internationale
pour déportation et ou transfert illégal
de personnes seules quelques 300 enfants
Ukrainiens on peut retrouver leur
famille
la France doit faire tout ce qui est en
son pouvoir pour contraindre la Russie à
organiser le retour de tous les enfants
Ukrainiens enlevés pour cela le
gouvernement doit cesser de privilégier
les intérêts économiques en alourdissant
les sanctions contre la Russie dans ce
secteur et en plaidant pour un
élargissement de ses sanctions au niveau
européen la France doit également faire
son maximum pour soutenir la Cour pénale
internationale mais aussi euro juste
l'équipe commune d'enquête sur les
crimes internationaux présumés en
Ukraine et le centre international
chargé des poursuites pour le crime
d'agression contre l'Ukraine
madame la ministre la période n'appelle
pas plus de négociations et plus de
diplomatie avec la Russie elle appelle à
plus de fermeté et à plus de cohérence
entre les paroles et les actes du
gouvernement car Auris d'alimenter la
machine de guerre de Vladimir Poutine le
gouvernement continue sa coopération
avec la Russie dans certains secteurs
nous le voyons avec le chantier de la
centrale nucléaire de Pâques Hongrie la
constitution de deux nouveaux de deux
nouveaux réacteurs nucléaires pour cette
centrale et pilotée par l'entreprise
russe rosatum malgré cela le
gouvernement a donné son feu vert à
l'opérateur français framatum pour sa
participation au projet cette décision
est inacceptable si l'industrie
nucléaire n'est pas visée par les
sanctions internationales contre la
Russie il est important que la France
respecte ses engagements nous ne pouvons
pas participer à des projets qui
risquent d'alimenter la machine de
guerre russes et nous comptons sur vous
madame la ministre
ce matin le président zellenski vient
d'arriver à La Haye pour rencontrer les
dirigeants de la Cour pénale
internationale à travers ce débat nous
lui transmettons tout notre soutien et
notre exigence en matière de justice et
pour une condamnation sans équivoque de
crimes de guerre et de crimes contre
l'humanité par la communauté
internationale merci
[Applaudissements]
merci la parole est maintenant à Bernard
buis pour le groupe RDP
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur l'Ambassadeur mes chers
collègues le simple mot
déportation réveil dans notre esprit
dans notre imaginaire collectif le
terrifiant spectre des heures les plus
sombres de notre humanité il y a encore
quelques décennies des millions
d'individus innocents étaient déportés
et exterminés pour une raison aussi
simple qu’épouvantable ils étaient juifs
aujourd'hui comme une irrémédiable
rengaine historique le même type
d'exaction insoutenable et perpétrée
contre les enfants Ukrainiens lors de
déplacement contraints et forcés en
Russie en effet le gouvernement
ukrainien déplore
19384 mineurs déportés et seulement 361
ayant réussi à échapper aux griffes de
l'aigle bicéphale grâce aux opérations
menées par les on
au moins autant de familles déchirées de
mer brisées par la disparition de leur
raison de vivre de la chair de leur
chair l'université de Yelle démontre
dans son rapport au moins 43 cas
devrait-on les nommer 40 concentrations
répartis sur l'ensemble du territoire
russe ou contrôlé par la Russie à cela
s'ajoute le triste bilan de 500 enfants
tués et 1000 blessés en deuyant un pays
déjà meurtri dans son cœur mes chers
collègues nous le comprenons tous ces
aimants les 7,5 millions d'enfants
Ukrainiens présents dans le pays avant
l'éclatement de la guerre sont les
tristes victimes collatérales d'un
conflit qui s'éternise au grand dames
d'une population qui ne cicatrisera
jamais totalement les plaies ouvertes
par une telle barbarie alors peut-on
parler de crimes d'agression
indéniablement peut-on parler de crimes
de guerre à ne pas douter oui
réjouissons-nous que les instances
internationales et ukrainienne ce soit
dès le début appliqué à réunir les
preuves de crime commis par les Russes
en Ukraine que dire ensuite des
qualifications de crimes comme
l'humanité voire de génocide la notion
de génocide est un manipuler avec une
certaine prudence raison pour laquelle
il nous faut en discuter aujourd'hui
amorcé par de nombreux juristes la
discussion tourne autour du débat
juridique mais si les juges trancheront
un jour la question je note cependant
que l'ancien garde des sceaux maître
repère Badinter considère que cette
forme insidieuse de département des
enfants Ukrainiens vers la Russie ça
veut dire une forme de génocide culturel
les actions de l'armée russe en Ukraine
montre donc en réalité l'intention de la
destruction et de l'humiliation de la
population civile l'écrasement de leur
identité et de leur intégrité mais
au-delà du droit au-delà des
qualifications juridiques du droit pénal
international
il est avant tout question de vie
humaine en face aux tortures qui sort
les déportations les conséquences de
celles-ci sur les vies humaines sont en
réalité dramatique si les déportations
des enfants de tout âge cause des dégâts
multiples celles des nourrissons
Ukrainiens risque d'engendrer sur eux
des séquelles psychologiques
irréversibles et pour cause imaginons
que le conflit sans Lise encore pendant
plusieurs années comment rendre possible
le retour en Ukraine des enfants
déportés en Fédération de Russie si ces
mêmes enfants grandissent ailleurs que
dans leur pays natal sans pouvoir
s'identifier comme étant ukrainien sans
repère ni souvenirs admettons que la
situation déjà sidérante à laquelle nous
faisons face pour et s'aggraver
davantage et ce serait toute une nation
qui se retrouverait privée d'une partie
de ses enfants face à de tels risques
l'action n'est plus une option sans
reprendre à mon compte l'ensemble des
critiques prononcées dans cette
hémicycle à l'enconque des instances
internationales que sont l'ONU et
l'UNICEF je dois également reconnaître
que je m'interroge si l'action de
l'UNICEF des soins est-ce pour autant de
sa responsabilité autrement dit la
situation actuelle ne doit-elle pas nous
conduire à repenser le fonctionnement et
l'articulation de cette instance
mondialement reconnue avec l'ONU depuis
sa création le 24 octobre 1945 à chaque
fois qu'un événement a eu des
conséquences tragiques pour les enfants
dans le monde l'UNICEF s'est engagée en
agissant sur le terrain de manière
concrète et incontestable mais dans la
guerre entamée depuis plus d'un an en
Ukraine guerre qui malheureusement
figurera peut-être demain dans nos
livres d'histoire comme étant l'un des
conflits majeurs du 21e siècle force est
de constater que l'action de l'UNICEF
devrait être renforcée et c'est pour
attendre atteindre cet objectif dans
l'intérêt des enfants qui soient
ukrainien aujourd'hui ou d'ailleurs
hélas dans les affron de demain que la
question de la réforme de l'ONU se
dresse inévitablement devant nous à
l'heure où les acteurs du conflit en
Ukraine incite à l'escalade en appelant
hier et je cite éliminer le président
ukrainien et ski en représailles à une
attaque présumée de drone contre le
Kremlin imputé par Moscou à Kiev qui de
son côté ni tout implication nous devons
préparer le moment venu ou le dictateur
Vladimir Poutine et ses complices seront
traduits en justice car comme le
souligne l'auteur Raoul Jean thémar
Gemma si les historiens relèvent les
faits les juges eux doivent examiner les
intentions rechercher les mobiles
analyser les modalités d'exécution
identifiées et entendent des auteurs
directs et indirects ainsi que les
victimes et pour reprendre des
récemments du maître Robert Badinter
lors de la présentation de son dernier
ouvrage nous avons le devoir de préparer
le jugement d'homme comme Poutine et de
réunir toutes les preuves à cet effet
merci André pour ton implication sur
sujet et ainsi avoir provoqué le débat
la parole est un Jean-Yves Leconte pour
le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
nous évoquons ici un drame le plus grand
transfert de population forcée de masse
en Europe depuis la Seconde Guerre
mondiale et il s'agit d'enfants
c'est transfert forcés avaient commencé
depuis 2014 dans les territoires
Ukrainiens occupés par la Russie en
Crimée et dans dombases mais ils sont
malheureusement devenus à très grande
échelle depuis l'agression russe du 24
février 2022 contre l'ensemble de la
nation ukrainienne certains certaines
sources ça a été dit évalue jusqu'à 700
000 enfants actuellement en Russie la
Russie prétend que ce sont des mises à
l'abri le Défenseur des droits
Ukrainiens estime lui à au minimum 150
000 enfants
déportés de cette manière et un peu plus
de 19 fils enfants sont clairement
identifiés sur le titre territoire russe
de manière formelle
43 centre dans lequel serait passé au
minimum 6.000 enfants selon les sources
et les observations faites ça a été dit
souvent par le biais de pseudo colonies
de vacances en forçant en zone occupée
des rafles dont les descriptions sont
parfois froides dans le dos dans des
écoles dans des centres d'aide sociale à
l'enfance dans les territoires occupés
par la Russie
des séparations à l'occasion du conflit
ou lors des centres de filtration en
particulier lors de l'évacuation de
Mario Paul voilà comment on sépare les
enfants de leurs parents voilà comment
on transfère de manière forcée les
enfants
Ukrainiens vers la Russie
les il est tellement difficile de
sourcer en de savoir où sont ces enfants
et les identifier que seul 360 ont pu
revenir ensuite vers l'Ukraine auprès de
leurs parents avec souvent des risques
pris par ces personnes pour aller
chercher leurs enfants et les ramener
dans leur pays certains échanges se font
entre prisonniers russes et enfants
Ukrainiens mais cela reste très faible
on peut rajouter à ces observations ce
qui s'est passé à Zapo Roger président
ukrainien le rappelait dans une
interview le personnel de la de la
centrale nucléaire de sapeur Roger à
energoda a vu la plupart de ses enfants
capturés et un stage fait sur eux si
vous ne présente plus vous ne prenez pas
la nationalité russe vous ne reverrez
plus vos enfants voilà comment
fonctionne la Fédération de Russie sur
la base de suffisamment de preuves
c'est sur ces bases là que demande à
d'arrêt ont été
par la Cour pénale internationale vers
d'une part le président russe et d'autre
part par Maria Belova la supposé
commissaire au droit des enfants russes
et il est clair qu'il que le reste de la
chaîne de commandement et d'exécution de
ces crimes ne sera pas non plus
impuni et cela sera très clairement le
cas on doit aussi constater que ce
mandat d'arrêt de la CPI conduit
aujourd'hui les autorités d'Afrique du
Sud a suggéré au président russe de ne
pas venir semer des briques parce qu'il
serait en risque d'être en état
d'arrestation on constate aussi par de
multiples témoignages que les enfants
qui sont ainsi transférées de force vers
la Russie subissent des formations
idéologiques des séparations
d'une volonté de on les force à renoncer
à la nationalité ukrainienne on les
remonte contre contre la nation
ukrainienne et leurs anciens parents on
nie leur filiation c'est c'est des
éléments constitue des infrasantes à un
crime de génocide et il n'est pas du
tout impossible qu'à la fin l'ensemble
de la chaîne de commandement et
d'exécution de ces crimes puissent être
qualifié effectivement de crimes de
génocide ça a été dit aussi la société
russe malgré une propagande et des
incitations à l'adoption très forte et
particulièrement réservée sur ce qui se
sur ce qui se fait finalement assez peu
d'adoption se font et ce sont des
institutions religieuses sans contrôle
ou la maltraitance et le lieu commun qui
recueille entre guillemets ses enfants
c'est réellement dans les conditions les
plus terribles et avec une société russe
qui n'est pas dupe de la propagande
pourtant très forte Dieu son régime et
n'accompagne pas nécessairement les
exactions des autorités des autorités
russes rupture des liens de filation
pour les quelques centaines qui ont été
adoptés l'effacement de leur état civil
ukrainien alors que les parents sont
vivants ça aussi ce sont des crimes et
madame la ministre il faudrait être en
particulier vigilant dans la manière
dont finalement ces étapes sont faites
parce que que ce soit dans l'effacement
d'un état civil qui existe et donc
l'émission par la Russie d'un état civil
inexact faux falsifier la mise en place
de nouveaux documents d'identité il
faudrait être vigilant sur le fait que
aucune société européenne ou française
ne participe à la mise en place de ces
nouvelles
identités je crois que c'est important
d'autre part
nous pouvons et nous devons parler de
punir aucune inintérité pour personne
mais le plus urgent c'est de penser à
ses enfants et de réparer de faire en
sorte que le plus vite possible il
puisse revenir et retrouver leur famille
dans ce cadre je dois saluer
sur ce point la mobilisation de la
France et d'un certain nombre de
d'éléments de la société civile
française d'abord l'association pour
l'Ukraine qui a fait des communications
très précises sur ce point au bureau du
procureur de la Cour pénale
internationale là le Conseil national
des barreaux qui lui aussi a fait des
missions en Ukraine avec un certain
nombre de propositions très précises et
amener la première délégation officielle
d'avocats européens en Ukraine sur ce
point l'application réunit l'Ukraine
faite par un certain nombre de Français
vivant à l'étranger et qui ont subi des
séparations forcées d'enfants et qui par
leur expérience avaient développé une
application qui est aujourd'hui
a été développé et à évoluer et a été
développé en particulier avec les
autorités ukrainiennes aussi pour
permettre aux enfants et aux familles
ukrainiennes de se retrouver lorsque
c'était possible enfin les résolutions à
l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat et en
particulier au Sénat l'initiative
d'andrégatolin pour rappeler combien
nous ne pouvons pas tolérer cette
situation et combien au-delà de la
constatation de l'infraction et de la
punition il était indispensable de
réagir au plus vite alors ça a été dit
aussi la Russie prétend que c'est au nom
du droit humanitaire qu'il fallait
sortir les enfants des zones de conflits
en absolu c'est vrai sauf que c'est pas
à un belligérant de le faire
bon et si c'est intelligent qu'il fait
c'est en soi un crime de guerre et
ensuite si on le fait et même qu'on
n'est pas belligent on ne le fait que de
manière momentanée et en ne cachant pas
l'identité l'identité ou en empêchant
pas l'identification or ils font tout ça
plus ensuite la négation de l'identité
ukrainienne de ses enfants il a
séparation et la négation des crimes de
filiation donc c'est en rien une action
de protection
si une action de séparation c'est une
action de séparation des enfants avec
leur origine avec leurs parents c'est un
crime de guerre et c'est probablement un
crime de génocide c'est la raison pour
laquelle
il n'est pas tolérable de laisser ceci
impuni ou de ne pas aller jusqu'au bout
et au regard de l'engagement de notre
pays de la société civile de notre pays
de du Parlement français le gouvernement
lui aussi doit prendre un certain nombre
d'engagement madame la ministre d'abord
l'UNICEF l'UNICEF est une organisation
des Nations Unies et les Nations Unies
fonctionnent comme fonctionnent les
Nations Unies compte tenues de
de la place de la Russie au Conseil de
sécurité mais toutefois il est
indispensable qu'aujourd'hui nous
fassions avec nos partenaires européens
et avec l'ensemble des des pays qui sont
sensibles à cette question à un maximum
de pression pour que l'UNICEF puisse
avoir la possibilité l'UNICEF est prête
mais l'UNICEF aujourd'hui n'a pas la
capacité d'accéder aux enfants qui sont
en Russie ceci doit être fait et la
France doit faire le maximum avec
l'ensemble de nos partenaires pour que
cela puisse se faire la deuxième chose
c'est que l'UNICEF doit pouvoir observer
faire un rapport d'obser sur tous les
actes constitutifs d'infraction et
permettre d'abord l'identification de
l'ensemble des enfants qui sont en
Russie de manière à leur permettre de
revenir dans leur famille enfin
la ministre il est important que la
conférence annoncée par la présidente de
la Commission de l'Union européenne sur
cette question soit à haut niveau avec
la participation de l'ONU de l'UNICEF et
du CICR je pense aussi qu'il
conviendrait compte tenu de la situation
que nous prenions l'initiative que vous
preniez
l'initiative de reprendre sur le métier
la PPL de Jean-Pierre sœur qui et qui
élargit les compétences du juge français
en matière de crime de guerre et de
crimes contre l'humanité enfin à ce
stade nous devons être vigilants sur ces
actions nous devons nous mobiliser pour
que la France soit à l'avant-garde de la
mobilisation et de la capacité de
l'UNICEF d'agir et rien ne doit manquer
rien ne doit manquer à notre solidarité
vis-à-vis de l'Ukraine et de son peuple
dans son combat pour la liberté longue
vie aux enfants d'Ukraine soit vers
[Applaudissements]
Laurent pour le groupe CRCE
madame la présidente madame la ministre
chers collègues le débat d'aujourd'hui à
l'initiative de notre collègue André
gatolin et du groupe RDPI braque a
raison le projecteur sur un des drames
les plus terribles vécu par les enfants
du crâne dans la guerre déclenchée par
la Fédération de Russie contre ce pays
les transferts forcés massifs d'enfants
et de déportation d'enfants Ukrainiens
vers la Russie est un crime
injustifiable que la résolution que nous
avons adoptée à peine très justement à
condamner si les chiffres ne sont pas
totalement
établis il est avéré en effet que ces
transferts forcés totalement contraire
au droit et conventions internationales
sont massifs
combien d'enfants concernés parmi les
centaines de milliers d'enfants
Ukrainiens déplacés par la guerre nous
ne le savons pas exactement
un système de collecte de données gérées
par le gouvernement ukrainien indique
que 16000 enfants aurait été transférés
de force vers la Russie avant la fin du
mois de février l'OMG américain conflits
observateurs
watch évoque plusieurs milliers
d'enfants il est donc manifeste que les
transports forcés sont massifs et
violent gravement le droit humanitaire
international il constitue au minimum un
crime de guerre comme la d'ailleurs
souligné l'ONU dans son rapport public à
la mi-mars
les constatations déjà établies montrent
comment la Russie inscrit ce projet de
transfert forcés dans son projet
d'annexion ultra-nationaliste des
territoires
occupés ont tentant de russifier
l'identité et l'avenir de ses enfants au
déni de leurs droits de leur histoire
familiale et du droit international
la résolution insiste à juste raison sur
la nécessité d'identifier de documenter
et de recenser tous les cas de transfert
forcés de départements afin de se donner
les moyens d'enrayer ce sinistre au
projet et donc condamner les
responsables le crime qui frappe ses
enfants n'est malheureusement qu'une des
nombreuses facettes du drame que
provoque des drames que provoque cette
guerre sur la vie et l'avenir des
enfants Ukrainiens vivant dans les
territoires visés par le conflit
l'UNICEF dénonce en permanence les
ravages multiples causés par les guerres
sur les enfants près de 250 millions
d'enfants grandissent dans le monde en
zone de conflits et 125 millions sont
directement impactés par les violences
de tous ordres comme en témoigne ce qui
se passe en ce moment en Ukraine
les enlèvements de masse visant les
enfants font partie des nouvelles
tendances inquiétantes relevées par
l'UNICEF dans les conflits où s'ajoutent
les situations de déplacer de réfugiés
la perte des parents la destruction des
maisons familiales les violences
sexuelles les blessures du notamment au
bombardements en zone peuplée la
déscolarisation
l'errance en cas de perte de la famille
la malnutrition les maladies c'est ce
que vivent les enfants dans les zones de
guerre en Ukraine le plus terrible c'est
que ces mots affectent non seulement le
présent de ses enfants tant que durera
cette guerre mais que les traumatismes
vécus affecteront toute leur vie future
les arracher à leur pays à leur famille
est une violence de plus que le projet
politique de Poutine rend plus
insupportables encore les transports
français forcés d'enfants Ukrainiens
sont un miroir grossissant et
particuliens particulièrement inhumain
de toutes les blessures psychiques
qu'imposent la guerre aux enfants du
crâne
comme le font toutes les guerres
aux enfants toujours extrêmement
vulnérables en raison de leur âge et de
leur dépendance aux adultes
il y a déjà plusieurs mois en août 2022
la directrice générale de l'UNICEF
Catherine Russell l'on sait déjà un cri
d'alerte sur cette situation je la cite
la quasi-totalité des enfants
Ukraine vivent des événements
traumatisants et ceux qui ont fui
coureur d'être séparé de leur famille et
d'être victimes de violence de
maltraitance d'exploitation sexuelles et
de traite des êtres humains
déclara-t-elle
nous savons que la Russie exploite
honteusement cette détresse avec les
transferts forcés
que le débat que nous avons aujourd'hui
nous invite aussi à entendre l'appel
qu'elle lançait en conclusion de cette
déclaration à l'époque l'UNICEF appelle
excusez-moi
l'UNICEF appelle par conséquent un
cessez le feu immédiat en Ukraine et à
la protection de tous les enfants si les
enfants
Ukraine ont un besoin immédiat de
sécurité de stabilité
d'accès sans danger à l'éducation de
services de protection de l'enfance et
de soins psychosociaux c'est de paix
dont ils ont besoin avant tout le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste a soutenu pour toutes ces
raisons la résolution qui était en débat
au Sénat et se réjouit que ce débat est
aujourd'hui était provoqué par nos
collègues du groupe RDPI je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
c'est à vous
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les présidents de commissions
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs et
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
vous l'avez dit vous avez été vous
l'avez tous dit l'agression russe en
Ukraine à des conséquences terribles des
conséquences épouvantables sur les
enfants et leurs droits sont massivement
violées et leur futur risque d'être
brisés
la Russie à sciemment bombardé des lieux
dans lesquels nul ne peut ignorer que se
trouver des enfants des hôpitaux des
maternités des écoles
la Russie est responsable de meurtre de
blessures
de déportation de violences sexuelles
contre des enfants
alors permettez-moi d'abord de vous
assurer que nous ouvrons sans relâche
pour que les enfants Ukrainiens déportés
par la Russie retrouve sans délai leur
foyer
et les proches auxquels ils ont été
arrachés puis confiées à des inconnus
monsieur le sénateur Guillaume vous avez
raison la Russie a recours à la
propagande cynique avec l'affichage
public de ces transferts forcés de
fausses explications et plus récemment
la Russie a déversé ses mensonges lors
de sa présidence le mois dernier du
Conseil de sécurité des Nations unies
notre gouvernement s'est emparé très tôt
du sujet et la ministre de l'Europe et
des Affaires étrangères l'aborder
publiquement bien sûr mais aussi en
privé notamment aux Nations Unies un an
après le début de l'agression russe en
Ukraine et à Genève au Conseil des
droits de l'homme
comme vous l'avez souligné le premier
enjeu et la documentation des
déportations d'enfants en Ukraine dès le
4 mars 2022 la France a soutenue la
création d'une commission d'enquête
internationale indépendante par le
Conseil des droits de l'homme pour faire
toute la lumière sur les violations
graves des droits de l'homme dont ceux
des enfants
les conclusions de la commission sont
claires
des transferts ukrainiens ont été des
enfants Ukrainiens pardon ont été
transférés de force vers les territoires
temporairement occupés ou déportés vers
la Russie et placer dans des familles
russes vous l'avez nommé monsieur le
vice-président Laurent vous l'avez nommé
madame la sénatrice mélo monsieur le
sénateur buis s'est fait sont des crimes
de guerre
et avec 45 autres états Nous avons donné
mandat via le mécanisme de Moscou de
l'OSCE à une mission d'experts
indépendants pour établir un rapport sur
les transferts forcés d'enfants qui va
être présenté aujourd'hui au Conseil
permanent de l'OSCE
ces documentation vous avez été nombreux
à le dire elle est nécessaire à la
justice
et à nouveau vous avez également été
nombreux à le dire à ce stade les
différents mécanismes d'enquêtes n'ont
pas été en mesure d'estimer avec
précision l'ampleur de ce phénomène car
la Russie empêche l'accès des experts
indépendants c'est pourquoi Monsieur le
Sénateur n'est un registre des dommages
fait actuellement l'objet d'un travail
au sein du Conseil de l'Europe que nous
soutenons
et la semaine dernière nous avons
organisé en lien avec l'Ukraine et nos
partenaires une réunion ouverte du
Conseil de sécurité
sur les enlèvements et déplacements
forcés d'enfants lors de conflits armés
pour continuer toujours et sans relâche
d'alerter sur les violations de leurs
droits notamment en Ukraine nous ne
devons jamais faire baisser la pression
sur la Russie
vous avez également
souligner nombre d'entre vous et
notamment monsieur le sénateur Leconte
la nécessité que les auteurs de crime
commis contre les enfants ne restent pas
impuni de même madame la vice-président
grunis et bien notre d'entre vous
la lutte contre l'impunité pour les
auteurs des crimes commis en Ukraine et
en particulier à l'encontre des enfants
et notre priorité en mars dernier la
Cour pénale internationale
estimant qu'il existe suffisamment
d'éléments pour établir leur implication
dans la déportation et le transfert
d'enfants ukrainien a émis des mandats
d'Arrée contre Vladimir Poutine et Maria
lova Belova qui a le titre de
commissaire russe pour les Droits de
l'Enfant titre ironique comme vous
l'avez souligné monsieur le sénateur le
compte
c'est un signal très fort
l'effet commis contre les enfants que
nous dénonçons avec nos partenaires sont
d'une extrême gravité et nul ne peut
échapper à la justice ou se soustraire
assez responsabilités
et c'est pourquoi nous continuerons
d'apporter tout notre soutien à la cour
pour qu'elle puisse mener à bien son
enquête et pour que justice soit rendue
victime de ses atrocités comme la
ministre coloniale a rappelé au
président et au procureur de la CPI le
12 avril dernier à la haie
je vous rappelle que nous avons des
magistrats également en Ukraine nous
avons un laboratoire d'ADN nous avons
des policiers qui tous servent à
documenter tous les crimes et exactions
commis par la Russie en Ukraine
et nous continuerons d'apporter cette
notre appui au travail des juridictions
extrêmes qui bénéficient comme je viens
de dire de l'expertise criminalistique
logistique et technologique française
enfin c'est la dernière partie vous
l'avez mentionné
la protection des droits et des enfants
nous avons augmenté notre soutien
financier à l'Unicef en 2023 et avec
l'UNICEF nous avons engagé une campagne
internationale pour l'universalisation
des principes et engagements de Paris
relatifs aux enfants associés aux forces
armées ou au groupe armés désormais
soutenu par 114 états
le compte madame la vice-présidente
granny nous œuvrons pour que l'UNICEF
puisse agir dans cet univers d'agression
épouvantable
menée par là aussi
madame la vice-présidente sur les sujets
d'une conférence multilatérale nous
travaillons avec la Commission
européenne en vue d'une conférence sur
le rapatriement des enfants Ukrainiens
déportés l'organisation de cette
conférence a été annoncée le 23 mars par
la présidente Ursula funderlayen j'ai
bien entendu votre demande que celle de
vos collègues de participation à haut
niveau je crois que c'était
effectivement essentiel
avant de conclure monsieur le sénateur
Gontard sur le sujet du nucléaire la
France veille au strict respect de
l'ensemble des sanctions européennes
adoptées contre la Russie et à ce stade
l'Union européenne n'a pas adopté de
sanctions visant le nucléaire mais nous
dialogons avec nos partenaires européens
et avec les autorités ukrainiennes avec
des sanctions dans le dans le but
d'avoir des sanctions ciblées dans ce
domaine
voilà en conclusion monsieur les
sénateurs gatelin
je voudrais vous remercier
personnellement de votre engagement sur
ces sujets cet engagement important
crucial comme je le disais nous devons
jamais oublier ce sujet est toujours
toujours le rappeler pour qu'il soit
d'actualité et je me réjouis que votre
proposition de résolution était adoptée
en commission des affaires européennes
si vous me le permettez moi aussi comme
d'autres merci André et je vous remercie
d'ailleurs monsieur gatelin
souhaitez-vous quelques conclusions
oui merci madame la Présidente à mon
tour de reparler pour vous remercier
tous vous avez tous remercié mais je
crois que c'est devenu un travail
collectif alors c'est vrai qu'on a face
à cette situation
aberrante absurde violente le sentiment
d'impuissance
et en même temps je me dis que de chemin
parcouru quand pour la première fois
j'ai été interpellé sur cette question
par un collectif de chercheurs de 130
chercheurs ou universitaires qui
s'appelle pour l'Ukraine leur liberté la
nôtre dans certains membres sont là dans
les tribus en fin d'année passée
personne n'y croyait quand ils ont
déposé leurs mémorandum extrêmement
bon mémorandum fait avec l'aide de
grands juristes français internationaux
spécialisés dont maître Daoud
tout le monde était dupitatif sur le
fait que la CPI se mobilise on nous
disait il faut créer un tribunal spécial
jamais les instances existantes ne
bougeront et bien cela a été fait et
quand j'ai déposé ma déposition la
première version le 10 février je
demandais à la CPI de faire quelque
chose entre-temps début mars le
procureur s'est déplacé a pris des
décisions et puis il y a eu l'énoncé de
ces deux mandats d'arrêt internationaux
donc contre Vladimir Poutine et Madame
Maria lovela bellova et c'est un début
c'est quelque chose et surtout le sujet
sur la place publique et la place
publique internationale je crois que
c'est important alors on appelle ça
faire du Naaman shame moi je le traduit
nommer et mettre au banc métro banc ça
veut dire bannir mais c'est aussi demain
mettre devant le bon de la justice et
c'est ce que nous devons faire et on
préparant les preuves en développant en
idant nos amis écrivains en aidant les
familles qui souffrent à précisément
documenter préciser il faut le faire
vite parce que l'épreuve déjà une partie
des preuves ont disparu ont été
éliminées c'est absolument
urgent que nous allions plus avant alors
je suis heureux on n'est pas la première
chambre contrairement à ce que je
croyais avoir adopté une résolution
parce que chez nous le processus est un
peu plus long c'est le Parlement
polonais le 30 mars dernier qui a fait
une résolution extrêmement dure violente
qui parle même de trafic humain
concernant les enfants Ukrainiens mais
je suis ravi que l'Assemblée
parlementaire du Conseil de l'Europe est
voté à l'unanimité une résolution de la
semaine passée
en janvier dernier lorsque je suis
intervenu de mon dans
Alexandra mavicoupe qui est la
directrice du Centre pour les libertés
civiles
ukrainien que j'ai évoqué cette question
là c'était pas un sujet d'actualité
c'était pas encore un sujet aujourd'hui
il se passe quelque chose dans l'opinion
et quand je vois que effectivement les
gouvernants d'Afrique du Sud comme
c'était rappelé par mon collègue
Jean-Yves Leconte mettre la pression sur
Vladimir Poutine pour qu'ils ne se
rendent pas à la prochaine réunion des
briques où il est logiquement invité
parce que ils savent qu'ils seront dans
l'obligation de l'arrêter je me dis
quelque part la répercussion est forte
quand j'entends le président zenenski
après interpellé le président
interpellé le pape François pour dire
faites quelque chose pour les enfants
ukrainiens peut-être des autorités
internationales morales et bien c'est à
votre tour aussi c'est nous faisons
notre part nous payer occidentaux nous
payer européen parce que nous sommes
peut-être en l'occurrence aujourd'hui un
seul et même peuple mais tout le monde
doit s'investir dans cette question je
crois que ce qui était engagé là est
extrêmement important je voudrais
remercier tout le monde mais je veux pas
être trop long je remercie Pascal
grenier pour cette très belle citation
de ce génie cine qui lit la violence
comme moyen d'action au mensonge comme
règle c'est c'est malheureusement c'est
terrible on se rend compte que nous
sommes déjà bien avancés dans le 21e
siècle et que nous en sommes toujours à
des méthodes qui nous inquiète et qui
nous font peur donc madame la ministre
je crois effectivement nous avons
peut-être plus que d'autres pays la
France sur ce sujet là beaucoup à dire
et beaucoup à faire que l'UNICEF bien
sûr elle a été très critiquée moi quand
je discute avec les autorités
ukrainiennes elle est aussi très
présente sur le terrain
pour aider en Ukraine parce que quand on
sait la souffrance psychologique des
enfants dans la partie ukrainienne qui
subissent la guerre et les bombardements
et bien si l'UNICEF ne se sent pas en
mesure d'agir en Fédération de récits au
moins elle double ses moyens
d'intervention sur les territoires
Ukrainiens sauver les corps disait
Albert Camus il faut sauver les corps
les âmes et de devenir de ses enfants je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
je vais suspendre la séance pour
quelques instants juste pour permettre
la rotation au bord du gouvernement et
de la Commission
les suspendus